[Musique]
bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro de page
avec un sommaire assez chargé puisque
nous allons évoquer évidemment la
situation sanitaire nous allons aussi
parler de la réforme du mode de scrutin
faute qu'il introduire la
proportionnelle c'est ce n'est pas une
question technique c'est une question de
vie de la démocratie on va parler aussi
des élections régionales
et puis du projet qui se discute
actuellement à l'assemblée on appelait
autrefois projet sur le séparatisme même
dans ce projet pour renforcer les
valeurs de la république et pour en
parler et bien nous avons justement avec
nous le député de la 9e circonscription
des yvelines vice président du groupe
modem à l'assemblée c'est bruno billien
bonjour bonjour si la stéphane moreau
doyen honoraire de diversidad verser 50
ha et professeur de droit à l'université
de versailles-saint-quentin vincent
couronne vous enseigne aussi à
l'université vous êtes le fondateur des
surligneurs qui traque les fake news
dans la politique et en plateau florence
mercadé choqué bonjour vous êtes avocate
au barreau de versailles et jean charles
lajoie ni vous êtes éditeur
bonjour tu étais éditions la joie ni
absolument alors on va commencer à voir
évoquer la situation sanitaire mais où
est passé le confinement
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
là c'est vrai qu'on l'avait annoncé
partout même des ministres disait qu'il
serait serré jusqu'à vendredi
toutes les chaînes disait voilà on se
prépare au confinement le premier
ministre je crois même elle avait lu et
même plus ou moins annoncée et puis et
puis
le chef de l'état semble-t-il emmanuel
macron a pris la responsabilité de
changer de solution est finalement
d'éviter le confinement je vais
recommencer avec vos bruno rigal est ce
que il ya plusieurs choses importantes
d'abord le fait qu'il ya un chef qui
décide à écouter d'abord je vais revenir
sur tes ce comportement très sain je
vais revenir deux conscients déclaration
2 avec abriel attal c'est cette partie
là il avait bien dit on peut aller d'un
confinement couvre-feu qu'il sert et
jusqu'à confinement président du panic
c'était franchement traitée avec mépris
c'était une des hypothèses après je
pense qu'il est présent dans lé queens
il a redonné finalement le toit rigide
par rapport aux sanitaires
c'est apparaît difficile parce que c'est
une parier sur le fait qu' on va
maintenir l'économie parler sur la
responsabilité collective des uns et des
autres parce que sans gestes barrières
sans distanciation sociale sans
protections de chacun envers l'autre on
aura du mal à faire reculer et de 7,7 en
déni il faut au moins la stabiliser
voire la faire baisser ce qu'on serait
beaucoup en ce moment c'est ce fameux un
mystère la production en ce moment les
derniers chiffres qu'on a eues il entre
l'idée c'est qu'ils tombent en dessous
de 1
c'est à dire que 1 contaminés ne peut
pas contaminer plus d'un la compagnie
née et à ce moment là vous pourrez
essayer de passer l'hiver pascal
confinement tout de suite on serait
sorti du confinement dans une tanière
semaines pour être mais on s'est sorti
encore ayo d'hiver avec donc un facteur
hiver qui est favori finalement
l'organisation de virus pour finir le
variant angles et même si j'estime ans
et se multiplient si l'outil qui peut
être un peu moins le craignait attendons
de voir les chiffres l'échantillon était
très responsable pendant les vacances de
noël
s'ils ne sont là peut-être pouvoir
essayer de maintenir
il est tel qu'ils sont pas les trous
trop de la même si on voit que ça manque
quand même un petit peu mais si on
arrive à garder ses des choses et on
passe déjà comme ça en tant mieux sinon
de toute façon à un moment où dormir
vers le confinement c'est clair c'est au
fond une sorte de miracle chrétiens
milieu parce que tout le monde
s'attendait quand même même même si vous
avez raison de rappeler que voilà on
avait pris qu 1 au bout de la phrase de
lévriers la palme et mais c'est vrai que
tout le monde s'attendait au confinement
et finalement on peut faire autre chose
ça prouve quand même qu'on peut faire la
politique peut faire autre chose que ce
que préconisait l'ensemble des médecins
et notamment le conseil scientifique
surtout la politique peut faire de la
politique sert qu'un gouvernement peut
gouverner un président peut présider
sévère que on a enfin un président qui
s'appelle emmanuel macron et plus le
professeur delfraissy
voilà c'est une bonne chose c'est enfin
la prévalence de la politique sur le sol
sanitaire c'est très bien après on sait
très bien que le confinement
ça ne sert à rien parce que on va
confier pendant trois semaines et non
puis après on va d confiné ça va
recommencer
on va prendre un moment faut réaliser
qu'on ne va pas vivent confinés pendant
des années je voudrais la question tout
à l'heure parce que c'est intéressant si
on se placer dans l'hypothèse où il y
aurait chaque année pourquoi pas et ça
peut être ça peut être le cas
ce qui va compter environ
ses fans vont sauf peut-être c'est vrai
que il ya c'est très intéressant dans la
dans la façon de gouverner parce que on
est dans la roue fonde dans la stratégie
du peut-être peut-être que ça va marcher
peut-être que ça va pas marcher et on
est finalement à des façons de gouverner
au jour le jour
alors que l'habitude d'un gouvernement
c'est de prendre de la distance de
prendre presque de la hauteur ne pensait
à moyen ou long terme
là on est vraiment le nez sur le guidon
gouverner c'est prévoir
je suis d'accord mais encore faut-il
être en mesure de prévoir et on voit
bien que tant en france que dans la
plupart des autres l'état du moins d
état relativement démocratique et d etat
de droit
je pense qu'on peut pas faire confiance
dans les informations qui émanent de
certains systèmes politiques mais on
voit bien que la prévision que
l'anticipation est impossible ou au
mieux une certaine forme de prévention
mais en tout cas
évidemment qu'on navigue au jour le jour
je pense que ce nom confinement c'est
plutôt sur le plan sanitaire moi je je
je ne m'y connais pas il me semble
pourtant que les confinements ont été
utiles ne serait ce que pour faire
diminuer la pression la pression
hospitalière qui est une donnée
extrêmement importante mais sur l'option
le plan politique je trouve que ce nom
confinement est intéressant dans la
mesure où il place également les
citoyens devant leurs propres
responsabilités on a trop à mon avis
trop rapidement et trop fréquemment
dénoncé une forme d'infantilisation
c'était un terme qui a fait florès au
cours de ces derniers mois
on place les gens devant leur
responsabilité et on verra bien mais en
tout cas je trouve que sur le plan
politique en tout cas cette réponse
présidentielle est une bonne réponse
vous deviez des finances père cadets ya
une chose intéressante c'est qu'on a
attendu pendant des semaines et des
semaines beaucoup de critiques des
leaders de l'opposition je pense que
vous aviez bertrand notamment sur la
gestion de la crise on a l'impression
que la même macbook ça soit à gauche
perçoit à droite les critiques ont
tendance à se modérer peut-être parce
que tout le monde se dit mme se pose la
question est ce coffret autre chose ou
est ce qu'on ferait mieux la place du
gouvernement en place
c'est vraiment la question si oui alors
effectivement le président a mis un
petit peu tout le monde devant ses
responsabilités dessous il vient que de
finalement quelle que soit la décision
prend le gouvernement de toute façon
c'est la mauvaise phase on confine ses
volets on décline ses mollets on laisse
les écologistes et boudé
on y vend à éventuellement on va les
fermes et surtout pas donc c'est une
situation qui est compliqué finalement
cette espèce de solutions dit peut-être
la dernière chance je sais pas où je
l'avais le président en ayant en ayant
toutes les cartes en main notamment les
données économiques et vis des données
aussi de santé psychologiques et
psychiques des français parce que ça ça
tape sur le système de tout un chacun je
suis sûr parmi une parmi nous a mis la
larme dans la vraie responsabilité
politique et finalement voir la
confiance dans les citoyens c'est ce que
c'était fait mention disais tout à
l'heure en leur disant dollars c'est
très dense et porter la responsabilité
mais on pense que vous êtes capable 2
donc on vous donne la main hélas les
adversaires politiques
qu'est ce que vous voulez qu'ils disent
qu'est-ce que je m'en remets laval
finalement dans la main ou dans la
raquette des citoyens en leur disant au
nom nous tous en charge et on arrive à
s'en sortir
c'est difficile de critiquer
politiquement c'est une décision
est ce que c est que ça évident que
l'élection présidentielle est fini il va
avoir lieu en 2022
est ce que cette situation sanitaire va
beaucoup jouer est ce que ça sera
retenue peut-être favorable aux ou
défavorablement contre le président
sortant ce qui était difficile à dire si
la dire puisque on est quand même dans
une dans une situation d'imprévisibilité
parce qu'on ne connaît pas et en avance
comme on peut sur le plan sanitaire
donc si emmanuel macron arrive à
endiguer ce virus si d'ici la fin de
l'année à tout le monde et l'accident
voilà si tout le monde est vacciné si
les chiffres tombent
bah oui ça lui ça lui portera chance et
j'espère je pense que de là il aura de
deux sacrés chances de succès maintenant
par rapport aux autres mouvements
politiques
jusqu'à présent il ne faisait que
critiquer sans apporter de solutions
parce qu'il s'était bien incapable
d'apporter de solutions en tout cas d et
là comme disait monsieur le député il
est ils sont ils sont un peu coincé
parce qu'ils peuvent pas critiquer
quelque chose qui est raisonnable donc
emmanuel macron fait du en même temps je
vais protéger à l'économie mais en même
temps un peu essayer de refermer sur
l'économie de la problématique notamment
la des grands centres commerciaux qui
sont qui sont fermés pour essayer en
même temps de protéger à la santé des
français que ce soit la santé d'ailleurs
mental ou physique puisque je pense que
là les citoyens ont eu beaucoup de mal à
supporter un troisième confinement et
que là qu'ils puissent continuer à
sortir même s'ils doivent rentrer chez
eux à 18 heures c'est quelque chose
d'important donc il a réussi à trouver
un risque d' équipes misent espèces
d'espacés aux pays bas donc cet
équilibre est intéressant ce qui me
paraît très intéressante c'est que
valait plus la politique reprend un peu
ses droits
en tout cas au niveau gouvernemental
l'opposition est inexistante
bon bah ça avec ou sans que vide elle
l'est mais ce qui est important à mon
sens c'est l'émergence d'un nouveau
discours des intellectuels qui
reprennent un peu la parole et qui eux
ont un discours assez intelligent
quelques quelques-uns qui se disent
effectivement que la santé c'est bien
avec la liberté c'est pas mal aussi
qu'on devrait s'y attacher un petit peu
plus qu'il prenne la parole qui écrivent
des bouquins qui écrivent des équipes
qui prennent la position dans des
tribunes dans la presse écrite parce que
bien évidemment il faut pas attendre sur
les grands médias radio ou télévision
des propos dissonant ce que tout ça a
été évacué mais dans la presse écrite on
a encore la chance de pouvoir trouver
des intellectuels qui prennent la parole
et on peut être d'accord pas d'accord
mais au moins ils s'expriment et cdd
des endroits de liberté ça me semble
être la presse écrite donc c'est
important et puis que les intellectuels
arrive à reprendre un peu la main c'est
plutôt bien plutôt que des des opposants
qui n'en sont pas et qui sont terrorisés
à l'idée de 1,1 d'un éventuel procès
après je ne sais pas facile mais c'est
vrai qu'on fait qu'on tirera un peu les
conclusions de cette crise un moment
essayé il ya un élan d'humanisme c'est à
dire voilà on protège quand même les
plus des plus fragiles et en même temps
un accroissement du politiquement
correct
au cours de cette crise qui est assez
étonnant vincent couronne il ya aussi un
autre problème qui est celui de la
vaccination
il ya eu des pépins il ya eu des
critiques sur la gestion par la
commission européenne ce et puisque
c'est elle qui a pris en charge la
vaccination fallait l'achat des vaccins
en europe et des critiques sur la les
procédures qui ont été utilisés par
madame von der leyen lui effectivement
patrice la présidente de la commission
européenne avait insisté pour que les
vaccins soient achetés par par la
commission européenne au niveau de
l'union européenne a ensuite distribué
de manière égalitaire entre tous les
états membres
je pense était une bonne chose le
problème c'est que mon avis la ursula
von der leyen s'est prise c'était
prendre à son propre piège parce qu'elle
avait promis des vaccins à des prix
imbattables pas cher du tout que tout le
monde serait fournie en temps et en
heure et sauf qu'en fait elle n'a pas pu
avoir avec des prix très bas
elle n'a pas pu avoir la livraison
livraison en temps ordinaire comme elle
comme l'avait promis et là on a vu
notamment le laboratoire britannique
astrazeneca qui a dit écoutez moi j'ai
un problème sur de production en europe
donc du coup vous serez livrés vous je
vous ai promis 100 millions de vaccins
au 1er trimestre en fait vous n'aurez
que 30 millions et encore ils vont
arriver en retard
et là effectivement ursula von der leyen
a dit attendez c'est parce qu'on avait
pris le départ
sauf qu astrazeneca a dit oui mais enfin
vu ce que vous payez comme prix pour le
vaccin très bas fallait pas non plus
s'attendre à ce que vous soyez servi des
premiers et donc là il ya une bataille
un peu entre la commission européenne et
le royaume uni en filles étant
finalement derrière ça c'est une
bataille en fait union européenne
royaume uni tout ça au lendemain du
break site extrêmement symbolique est
donc là en fait il ya pas vraiment de
porte de sortie pour la président de la
commission européenne qui a été déjà
prise la main dans le sac par les médias
allemands pour avoir déjà plusieurs
reprises lorsqu'elle était ministre dans
le gouvernement merkel en allemagne pour
avoir fait des promesses comme ça un
petit peu intenable et finalement être
parti sans vraiment assumer les
responsabilités de cette promesse là
aujourd'hui il faut savoir quand même
parlement européen certains commencent à
parler vraiment d'une possible motion de
censure à l'encontre un la pression de
la commission européenne pour ça mais
justement pour nous il y ait parlé
d'europe vous êtes parce que yayi
en effet lorsque on peut critiquer dans
la procédure qui a été faite c'est
d'avoir voulu faire baisser les prix
parce que finalement c'est un c'est un
raisonnement à court terme puisqu'on
gagne plus d'argent si on vaccine le
plus de monde possible le plus vite
possible plutôt que vous en baisser le
prix des vaccins mais en même temps
est-ce que là l'idée que ça aurait été
mieux si chaque pays s'était débrouillé
pas une idée totalement totalement
fausses je pense qu'il joue un fausse
parce que parce que là les commandes au
total si je ne me trompe pas tous les
chiffres exacts il ya comment ma voisine
de 1 milliard de doses vaccinales même
des milliards de milliards de dollars
dont on n'a pas la nature des contrats
c'est ce que je trouve extraordinaire
dans l'histoire c'est ya un contrat
signé avec avec et ces chiffres des
chiffres qui sont annoncés dans les
contrats les laboratoires sont sont à
mon sens juridiquement obligés de
fournir lors le fait d'avoir négocié sur
2 milliards de doses d'un coup
effectivement les débris laissés comme
quand vous achetez en eau à n'importe
quel produit plus de 12 ans lâche un
membre important le prides et ça surtout
permis de rendre le vaccin gratuit alors
les mains totalement gratuit parce que
c'est l'état qui paye non le
contribuable avancer l'argent et être
remboursé par la sécurité sociale à m'en
aller
en tout cas pour la france
des siens pays à offrir à la fois les
tests et les vaccins graphique et du
coup la stratégie vaccinale de la france
paraît un petit peu idiote que ce qui
avait été un début puisque les doses qui
nous réserve peut heureusement il nous
en reste
l'on allait pour assurer au moins la
deuxième maxi nation déprimant vacciner
du mois janvier de manière à se voir ce
qu'ils soient doublés et puis comme ça
ça va nous permettre de tenir le coup
jusqu'au moment où des doses arrivant
vous avez joué face et astrazeneca
caddie kaleki les allées ont livré un
peu plus moderne a aussi indiqué
d'ailleurs on livre un peu plus
sanofi va swinguer confiseur à francfort
malgré les jours de foire je pense qu'à
un moment ou un autre ça va se régler le
problème avec astrazeneca s'est
angleterre c'est chasse quand même un
grand potager face à une pandémie cali
ciment parce que l'eau n'a rien fait en
matière de nids de confinement dit de
vous un défaut ni de protection des des
citoyens pendant des mois et des mois et
a surgi ce soit ne va rien onglet qui a
provoqué une pandémie d'exposants ciel
effectivement ils ont besoin à la limite
parce que la situation est beaucoup plus
délicate que dans beaucoup de pays
d'europe
ils ont besoin d'avoir un maximum de
vaccins pour essayer de faire baisser
cette tension de la pandémie avant -
c'est très compliqué cela alors
peut-être que dans les contrats avec le
sais pas je n'ai pas eu les couilles
mais s'il ya tout et c'est une purge
c'est peut-être c'est peut-être un des
reproches d'ailleurs qu'on peut faire au
fonctionnement de la commission
européenne c'est peut-être le secret et
après tous les conseils pour être public
et ça serait ça serait peut-être plus
plus
selon ce qu'a dit oui alors j'ai géré
les contres encore un gros personne et
ce nom mais ce
j'entendais des interviews sur ce sujet
ce que j'ai compris c'est que
astrazeneca bien évidemment amis dans ce
contrat qu'il n'avait qu'une obligation
de moyens c'est à dire que ils peuvent
éventuellement déroger au contrat s'il
démontre qu'en toute bonne foi ils
peuvent pas livrer et eux ils se cachent
derrière le fait qu'ils ont un problème
effectivement de production et je pense
qu'ils mettent en avant cette cette
obligation de moyens dont ils n'ont pas
d'éducation de résultats de livres et de
livrer les doses mais une obligation de
moyens donc en se cachant derrière le
phare se cachant ou pas d'ailleurs j'en
sais rien sur le fait qu'ils ont un
problème de production qui fait qu'ils
ne pourront pas produire autant et
qu'ils ne pourront pas livrer autant
soit on arrive à démontrer qu'ils sont
de mauvaise foi et que en réalité c'est
où ça grimpe au liban ils vont fournir
de huy à 40 millions lieu de ce disque
on n'oublie toujours c'est que quand
même les cils taux impressionnant il
faut vacciner 10 milliards de personnes
passaient c'est quand même absolument
incroyable et c'est vrai qu'en un an
quand même les ce qu'ont fait les
laboratoires est absolument
extraordinaire et les laboratoires ce
qui est extraordinaire j'attends avec
impatience fin août et la tête d'une
autre milice de la santé olivier variant
avec ces soi-disant à 70 millions de
français vaccinés d'abord il aura trouvé
4 millions de plus 4 millions de
français employeurs des décences la wii
mais des naissances prématurées une
prochaine annonce et d'un mois d'août ça
va ça fait court mais voilà 70 millions
font jeudi on sait très bien que ça
n'aura pas lieu sur les contrats 6 aussi
certains ont été publiés et j'ai vu
notamment le cours à astrazeneca est
effectivement comme le dit florence à la
raison et puis il prévoit bien une
obligation de moyens et c'est la voie
qu'a être un peu de mauvaise foi parce
qu'ils disent en gros on n'a plus les
moyens de les produire suffisamment en
europe mais par contre on les produit
toujours en abondance au royaume uni et
c'est pour ça que ursula von der leyen
est en place à un certificat
d'exportation c'est à dire que tous les
vaccins qui type le continent doivent
être déclarés auprès de la commission
européenne pour vérifier qui a pas de
mauvaise foi la part d'astrazeneca mai
mais voilà mais jusque là le secret de
ces contrats en fait il est dû à des
secrets industriels de l'énergie
c'est tous les contrats même conclu avec
un état avec un opérateur comme celui-là
en général son secret c'est pas dû à la
commission européenne
justement beaucoup entendu parler de
l'achat de licences sur les vaccins
alors c'est possible mais ce qu'il
oublie les gens qui trône sein c'est une
dernière fois les lignes de production
une ligne de production de vaccin ça
c'est pas en deux semaines donc c'est
encore un champ quand ça un petit peu la
politique politicienne qui ne peut pas
fonctionner dans la réalité du quotidien
en tout cas ça sera intéressant de votre
devoir tous les n'importe quoi qu on a
dit pendant cette crise a dit il y en a
il y en a un paquet juste un mot fait
stéphane mention il ya aussi dans la
décision des manuels macron j'y reviens
il ya aussi la situation économique il
ya aussi la situation de la dette de
l'état je crois que la dette de l'état
pendant la crise sanitaire ces sept cent
mille euros par minute d'accroissement
donc c'est quand même des choses énormes
et si on prend un peu de distance et
direction se dit au fond si cette crise
sanitaire et c'est un peu d'ailleurs
dans la mentalité des gens c'est un peu
ce qui se disent finalement c'est ce qui
est dur à à penser c'est qu'elle
continue alors qu'on pensait qu'elle
pourrait s'arrêter
mais si on se disait tiens mais il va y
avoir des crises sanitaires tous les ans
on voit bien que le confinement ne peut
plus être une solution parce que sinon
c'est la chute de l'économie c'est la
fcc voilà c'est de la suite des systèmes
de santé etc
c'était fait mention je suis de l'être
humain surtout fédérer au delà de
l'économie veut dire on ne peut pas
vivre confiné on n'est pas des rares on
n'est pas des animaux de laboratoire d
hors de question qu'on supporte un
confinement comme ça et légumes 30% par
enfin ça ce serait énorme et
économiquement c'est probablement
beaucoup plus gérable qu'humainement
parce que économiquement bas
effectivement bon visiblement le
les gourdes est un moment et un moment
le la théorie du quoi qu'il en soit quoi
qu'il en coûte
tu vas avoir ses limites tout le monde
sans dette en europe
de la même façon on emprunte en ce
moment de l'argent à 50 ans 52 donc
voilà c'est pas si grave que ça de la
dette se dire si la croissance repart
c'est donc ici une crise un confinement
la croissance de repartir bien sûr mais
mais on peut faire confiance à
l'économie est certaine vision du
capitalisme pour se régénérer tout seul
ça je suis pas trop inquiet messieurs
les gens vont devenir dingue
alors je voudrais que l'argent emprunté
qui soutient l'économie utilisent ce
moyen aussi pour faire un virage au
niveau économique et puis le réorienter
et l'aider à se réorienter sur des
problématiques écologiques et de climat
parce que on emprunte sur 50 ans mais
dans 50 ans dans quel état sera la terre
en même temps donc il faut aussi pouvoir
restructurer et réorienter à l'économie
ce qui est certain c'est que si les
enfin laisser des chiffres exacts je
pense qu fin de mars on aura cinq
millions de français vaccinés
peut-être que je vous pose la question
pour nos 1000 yens et stéphane manceau
est ce qu'une fois qu'on aura 5 millions
par exemple de français vaccinés est ce
qu'on pourrait leur permettre d'accéder
je ne sais pas au musée au théâtre de
reprendre une partie de la vie justement
envisageable ça dépend effectivement
parce que le vaccin kaiser et le monial
attend d'entendre que c'est de l'art
elle connaît très bien astrazeneca je
connais moins pour l'instant sur les ut
maitrîser et modern art outre des jours
ça secteur vous êtes protégés vont me le
fait de développer la m
pour autant est-ce que vous n'êtes pas
quand même contagieuse si vous avez une
charge virale importante
donc effectivement on pourrait imaginer
que ces gens là puissent sortir mais de
toute façon on gardera le masque
j'imagine les mesures de
hier encore pendant longtemps je sais ce
qu'on ait atteint 60% de la population
vaccinée à peu près seuil de l'immunité
collective
donc voilà il faut pas non plus trop
mettre aux gens que tout d'un coup parce
qu'ils ont eu la double dose qu'elle se
résorbe modern avait jeté leurs masques
et circuler dans la rue comme ils
veulent pas que ça se passerait comme ça
on est toutes les personnes vaccinées
ensemble dans un théâtre
ça n'a pas de problème c'est vrai que
pour elle accepte d'envisager grunge
évident alors un passeport sur ce point
mal si moi j'ai une petite divergence
avec le gouvernement ça m'arrive c'est
que moi le milieu de la culture des
terres des musées et c'est un jeu
n'aurait pas fermé parce que les mesures
barrières qui met en place sont
suffisantes surtout quand vous avez
plusieurs saisons entre deux personnes
mais que vous gardez les masques moi
j'aurais emmené à ces secteurs la
mauritanie long des chiffres qui
contredisent totalement ce que je dis
moi mais en tout cas c'est pas la même
chose d'aller aux termes que d'aller au
restaurant le mas que vous gardez sur le
nez il ya une distanciation dû résister
mais je suis trop un petit peu dommage
pour les maintiennent un petit peu sous
stéphane lancé en conclusion de ce
chapitre c'est là sur la situation
sanitaire à la conclusion vous êtes
terrible patrice et si l'essentiel et
cette avancée la brière donc il n'ya pas
de conclusion on navigue à vue chacun
fait ce qu'il peut la démocratie n'est
pas autant autant nier ou mise sous
cloche que on veut bien le dire ça et là
l'état de droit continuent à fonctionner
au regard de contraintes qui sont qui
était à la fois imprévisible et qui sont
des contraintes extrêmement forte
donc pas de conclusions pour l'instant
nous verrons bien
je crois qu'elles sont on ne peut on ne
peut rien dire de mieux
peut-être que ben il va falloir quand
même apprendre à vivre avec
vexé de plus en plus on va passer à la
politique et on va parler de la réforme
du mode de scrutin pour ou contre la
proportionnelle
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je vous propose
on va voir petites interventions de
quelqu'un que vous connaissez bien bruno
milliers de ces jean baptiste à mo'nique
qui est le maire de villepreux qui est
qui dirige le modem je crois dans le
département et qui au micro de wilfrid
richie situe justement l'importance de
ce débat plus aussi qu'une proposition
c'est un des principes qui n'a permis de
ceux de l'alliance entre françois bayrou
et emmanuel macron pour la
présidentielle de 2017
nous y sommes très attachés nous
espérons que le président la république
et du gouvernement puisse mener cette
réforme avant la fin du quinquennat
ou en tout cas s'engage très fortement à
le faire en début de quinquennat
prochain si le président ma couette et
amel candidats la tribune
mais aujourd'hui je crois que c'est
vital lié à une crise sanitaire il ya
une crise économique et sociale qui va
s'installer dans le pays pendant
plusieurs années peut-être il ne faut
pas qu'on ait une crise démocratique
on peut répondre justement à cette
inquiétude il faut absolument
aujourd'hui que nous envoyons notre mode
de scrutin il nous reconsidérerions
aussi le parlement voilà c'est
intéressant ce qu'il dit parce que c'est
on va parler évidemment de la technique
qu'est ce que c'est la proportionnelle
quelle proportion de députés pour être
élu à la proportionnelle mais au delà de
ça c'est une question de devis de la
démocratie ce que dit jean mathis la
monuc était intéressant au modèle mais
pour qu'on rejoigne le candidat mais on
sait qu on le voit bien que la
démocratie se délite sous cette vème
république encore plus depuis qu'on est
passé sous le quinquennat d'ailleurs
vous avez bien vu que si c'était valable
on va dire les tentes de l'eau le monkey
do et pierre et jusqu'à giscard
d'estaing le premier actionnaire a été
muté en on a une crise démocratique
d'accord après on nous ont dit oui mais
la proportionnelle c'est à relire
gouvernable je suis désolé sous la
quatrième république de cuisine 1951
leur part cela n'existe plus c'est
palace et dans l'arc en ciel qu'à tuer
la quatrième république par exemple
plutôt la constitution qui existait à
une autre c'est un besoin de
représentativité démocratique et de quoi
du parlement dans notre d
nous sommes les représentants du poi
comment vous voulez et expliquer aux
gens que si nous sommes les
représentants du peuple
leurs représentants ne sont pas
représentatifs de ce qui existe dans la
société
enfin vous voyez moi j'aime vous savez
très bien je ne partage en rien les
tests du rassemblement national
mais quand même devoir lise ont effectué
six ou sept députés à l'assemblée
nationale alors que marine le pen était
au deuxième tour mais pour ceux pour qui
ont voté dans la peine c'est juste
insupportable ils sont pas représentés à
la hauteur de leur poids politique dans
le pays
donc c'est une question d'amour
passionnelle doit arriver quand aux
critiques je suis désolé les sénateurs
sont les premières critiques et salons
enfin ils ont ils sont inclus à la
proportionnelle par les élus
et puis les municipalités et les régions
ont un scrutin proportionnel avec prime
majoritaire
et ça fonctionne parfaitement donc il
faut arrêter avec ce mythe de la
proportionnelle qui empêcherait la
france d'être gouvernés sera gouverné
avec plus peut-être de coalition plus de
poids du parlement où on a besoin le
parlement auprès de toi c'est interactif
les effectifs est important mais
l'équité son erreur représentants du
peuple et à ce titre là ils doivent
avoir aussi la mainmise sur l'action de
l'homme s'était fait devancer justement
on est dans dans une histoire de la vème
république il ya la tradition gaullienne
avec la prééminence du pouvoir exécutif
et qui s'accompagne en effet du scrutin
majoritaire est-ce que passait un
scrutin proportionnel c'est ça n'est pas
une autre histoire de cette république
est ce que ça serait est-ce que c'est
compatible au fond avec la vème
république
au fond moi je si vous voulez je ne me
pose même pas la question de la
compatibilité puisque rien n'est figé et
fort heureusement les régimes sont faits
pour pour évoluer vous savez bien que la
constitution la vème république a été
révisée 29 27 ou 28 choix depuis 1958 il
il appartient à chaque à chaque peuple à
un moment donné de se donner les règles
qu'ils estiment les meilleurs alors la
proportionnelle la proportionnelle
intégrale
évidemment le tout est de voir ce que ce
qu'on met derrière le terme ou
intentionnelle la prothèse de
l'intégrale
et elle et elle n'est pas en france une
une tradition de mon point de vue elle
elle n'est pas souhaitable mais comme le
signale et bruno myle yens tout à
l'heure les scrutins locaux du moins
pour les communes de plus de 1000
habitants et les autres collectivités et
est et la région admettent un scrutin
alors on dit toujours ce scrutin
proportionnel à correctifs majoritaire
moi je pense que c'est plutôt l'inversé
scrutin majoritaire correctifs
proportionnelle dans l'est dans
lesquelles au fond les choses se passent
extrêmement bien est ce que ce que ce
que disait le député bruno billien tout
à l'heure à propos du front national
rassemblement national dont je ne
partage absolument pas les les idées est
très vrai il est totalement anormal
qu'une force politique qui revêt un tel
poids politique dans la vie dans la vie
démocratique française ne soit pas plus
représenté au sein au sein du parlement
alors il ya en effet un tabou à l'égard
de la proportionnelle ce tabou de cette
crainte ou cette frayeur de
l'instabilité du pays ingouvernable etc
il me semble pas que ce soit vraiment
les perspectives tracées par au moins un
parent un correctif proportionnelle et
puis enfin quant à aux poids du
parlement
ça aussi c'est un serpent de mer depuis
depuis 1958 on sait que au fond les
parlementaires disposent dans les textes
de tous les outils nécessaires pour
peser plus s'il le souhaitait mais ceci
posé il est vrai que le phénomène
majoritaire le principe majoritaire tel
que nous le concevons dans notre culture
politique et bien a plutôt tendance à
paralyser ses outils à faire en sorte
qu'ils ne sont aux fondamentalement pas
suffisamment utilisé pour des
considérations purement purement
politique donc introduire une dose de
proportionnelle
le tout est de savoir dans quelles
proportions il me semble que c'est un
élément de respiration démocratique qui
est absolument nécessaire au régime
alors on va discuter du taux de
proportionnalité
de ces élections jean-charles redit hier
il ya aussi on voit bien la crise
démocratique on voit bien la
multiplication de ces commissions de
citoyens et s'est tiré au sort est ce
que c est ce que justement aussi si le
parlement était mieux représentés on
aurait moins besoin de ce genre de
j'espère parce qu'effectivement cette
multiplication de comités théodule comme
on disait à l'époque ça c'est juste
ridicule des des gens qui ne
représentent rien sont tirés au hasard
se demander si quelqu'un sort pas dans
la rue en disant allez vous vous avez le
document il avait une tête et en plus
avec les masques savoir s'ils ont une
bonne tête c'est difficile
pas donc on fait venir des gens ou sais
pas de quoi ils discutent que les
expertises ont aucune
alors effectivement comme le dit de
monsieur le député et monsieur le prof
de droit à l'instant une tout à fait
raison c'est le coeur de milliers de son
geste est fascinant c'est que le front
national ne soient pas représentés ou
quasiment pas l'assemblée est scandaleux
que ces sinistres gilet jaune
si j'ai envie de voter comme ça ils
pourront ils arrêteront de râler ils
voteront pour qui ils veulent
et puis voilà ce qu'ils verront un petit
sa santé ils seront représentés si si
jamais il arrive à trouver un candidat
ou à voter pour quelqu'un
et s'ils trouvent le chemin des bureaux
de vote ça c'est autre chose mais voilà
donc donc ça ne l'est pas tellement les
pressentis pour être que foutent
totalement positif enfin je veux dire à
quelqu'un que les gens puissent être
représentées ça calmera les râleries les
éventuels jacquerie enfin tout ce qu'on
peut imaginer la sommerau devez vous
interroger sur l'ajustement la dose de
proportionnelle qu'on pourrait
introduire mais pour deux millièmes je
reviens ce que disait stéphane manceau
ça veut dire que et vous vous le vivez
vos quotidiens il ya un parti
majoritaire qui est la république en
marche à l'assemblée vous êtes avec le
modem malgré de ce parti mais on voit
bien que souvent
le parti majoritaire disait autrefois
les godillots obéit à l'exécutif sans
faire entendre sa savoie
il ya même eu est d'ailleurs d'aider des
obeaux depp des rats au pardon well rmd
des groupes dissidents qui ont des scr
et d'ailleurs oui mais ça c'est inhérent
jeudi à se trouver dans la vème
république surtout depuis le quinquennat
parce que vous le voyez bien aussi nous
sommes guyot d'autres ont été liés aux
agents non qu'ils soient de droite ou de
gauche
voilà le schéma jory terre entraîne cela
après effectivement il ya un problème
politique qui fait qu'on peut pas ou ne
peut pas montrer ses ces dissonances aux
yeux du public parce que malgré tout si
on a élu majoritairement c'est pour
permettre de mettre en place le projet
du président de la république pour
lequel les français ont été bons mais en
coulisses
je veux dire que ça va te fermes souvent
sur certaines choses et à la chasse aux
voix qui arrive
iliad il ya des ya des réunions
ministérielles ou surchargés valoir ses
droits et défendre y ait des faux n'y
arrive pas on y arrive de plus en plus
bizarrement mais tant mieux mais c'est
comme ça que ça se passe mais c'est bon
c'est pas suffisamment claire
représentatif de la population c'est des
mains auraient lieu dans l'ensemble de
l'hémicycle
il serait certes animé mais avec la
devrait nos positions et pas seulement
des propositions de pure politique
politicienne
le débat serait intéressant enrichi par
les avis des uns et des autres et on
pourrait à vous dire que d'être je suis
pas tes lois sont mal faites quelque
chose de plus intéressant durant tout
cas ce que je vis depuis le début de
cette législature sans pour autant jeter
jours c'est vrai que oui la
proportionnelle et obligerait à avoir
des majorités sur certains textes de la
négociation 2
voilà ce qu'on ne fait pas aujourd'hui
vincent couronne justement alors sur
l'a12 de proportionnelle je crois que
françois bayrou parle d'une
proportionnelle intégrale avec un seuil
de 5% pour verser d'être départemental
et intégrale avec un seuil de 5%
vous êtes plutôt favorable à une
proportionnelle intégrale comme ça là où
une dose de proportionnelle comme
stéphane mention par exemple en fait je
trouve que la réflexion sur la
proportionnelle
elle doit avoir lieu dans le cadre d'une
réflexion globale sur le fonctionnement
des institutions en france typiquement
je pense que le peu de considération
qu'on a pour le parlement et pour la
représentativité qui l'a de ce scrutin
majoritaire des formes forcément la
représentativité du parlement en fait
elle s'explique essentiellement par le
poids écrasant la présidentielle qui est
considéré comme le seul thermomètre de
la volonté générale donc à partir du
moment où on a une élection
présidentielle qui à ce poids là il me
semble que un débat sur la
proportionnelle il est forcément biaisé
maintenant moi je suis plutôt favorable
de manière générale à la proportionnelle
ne serait ce que parce qu en europe
partout ailleurs il y à la
proportionnelle bon après ailleurs en
europe il ya proportionnelle est
proportionnel 1 il ya peut-être autant
de système à la proportionnelle qui lie
à l'état membre dans les européennes
c'est à dire 27 alors moins 1 parce qu'à
la france un scrutin majoritaire
mais il y en a partout on a des systèmes
mixtes comme en allemagne comme
aujourd'hui en italie où auparavant on
avait une proportionnelle intégrale et
il ya une loi en 2017 qui a réformé pour
mettre en place un système mixte où on
fait à la fois la proportionnelle et du
majoritaire cirque aux électeurs il voit
deux fois et ça fonctionne très bien on
peut pas dire que l'allemagne est
particulièrement instable politiquement
en réalité la question de la stabilité
du régime de la vitalité du débat etc
ce n'est pas une question de
proportionnelle c'est vraiment une
question d'équilibré entre les
institutions et c'est pour ça que moi en
france je suis d'accord pour commettre
en place de la proportionnelle mais
réfléchissons aussi au poids du
président la république et au moyen du
parlement aussi pour pouvoir contrôler
l'exécutif
c'est vrai que les régimes
proportionnelle vaut plutôt avec des
régimes parlementaires
et quand vous parlez de l'allemagne
c'est vrai qu'il ya une stabilité mais
combien de temps mais avant de
constituer un gouvernement mais un mois
à peu près pour que tout le monde soit
d'accord sur le programme mais ça ça n'a
rien à voir fin juin ça n'a rien à voir
s'il ya un lien regardée aux états unis
ils élisent le président est public et
il n'entre en fonction que trois mois
plus tard c'est pas grave
cheikh sarr et pourtant aux états-unis
sarah j'irai clairement présidentielle
avec au scrutin majoritaire à un tour
je veux dire c'est pas un souci est le
fait justement que en allemagne ou en
italie alors en belgique ça prend un peu
plus de temps mais pour des raisons plus
le conflits régionaux etc que de système
proportionnel
ça prend du temps mais parce que pendant
ce temps là qu'est ce qu'on fait et bien
on conclure discours concours au
gouvernement
c'est exactement ce qui se passe au
niveau du parlement européen la
commission qu'est ce dépassement 2019 on
a eu les élections européennes pas de
majorité absolue au parlement européen
comme preuve à chaque fois du coup la
commission da construire une coalition
sur lequel sur laquelle elle va
construire un programme avec un accord
de gouvernement
et c'est ce programme qui mise en oeuvre
pour les cinq années qui viennent et
finalement on se retrouve avec une
majorité parlementaire qui fait des
compromis pour mettre en oeuvre tout un
tas de promesses électoralistes et elles
ont intérêt à être tenu ses promesses
parce que si elles ne sont pas et bien
la coalition vole en éclats c'est une
condition d'efficacité politique en fait
de milliers alors un éclairage sur les
propositions du modem ça serait quelle
dose de proportionnelle
et est ce que il faut des réponses edel
départementale pour que les gens
connaissent leurs députés
question je suis plutôt pour parce qu'il
est aussi un autre reproche fait à la
proportionnelle c'est l'éloignement du
député des citoyens d'abord ça c'est
aussi un mythe est totale parce que
c'est l'organisation même de l'élu qui
fait qu'il est tranchante un de ses
citoyens à ne pas être élu à la
proportionnelle avec roger ses citoyens
sont presque aucun problème il a il à
lui à s'organiser et à ses autres choses
à travailler plus de terre avait déjà
travaillé plus peut-être ça s'est joué
sur la dose nous on est parti et sur une
dose à 5%
mais au-delà de ça moi je pense que
c'est au parlement français de décider
la dose de proportionnelle de 17 décidé
la façon dont on pourrait même leur
passionnel en france sinon cidre est
assez bien une proposition loi la
semaine de l'assemblée nationale qui
ouvre le débat à la toux des partis
politiques représentés à l'assemblée
nationale pour essayer de trouver un
consensus parlementaire déjà sur la dose
de proportionnelle
on m'a dit si elle est départementale ou
pas tout en sachant que nous sur le côté
des équipements on restera il est
excessivement rigide en est ce qu on
veut parler alain effectivement souvient
avec le site web si si vous êtes deviez
être consulté par sinon j'ai quand même
une question si jamais la réforme n'a
pas lieu c'est un casus belli entre le
modem et le la république en masse et
manuel mâcon pour tous pour dire les
choses honnêtement je ne saurais pas
vous répondre là dessus je sais pas
retourner là dessus vous voyez bien ce
qui se profile à l'horizon je me comme
combat pour les présidentielles en 2022
et même si on a encore à 18 mois et qui
peut se passer beaucoup de choses
vous voyez bien les forces en présence
on nous annonce au deuxième tour
honnêtement pour ma part mais je ne suis
pas le modèle pour ma part je ne vois
comment je pourrais g touré ne pas
continuer à soutenir le président mâcon
pour de légende eux le moche et voilà
que la réforme pourrait voir arriver
éventuellement chotard aussi là je serai
bien qu'elle ait lieu avant parce que ça
de voir un coup de jeune justement
parlement juste avant les élections
présidentielles de 2002 et enfin on va
retirer sur un régime très représentatif
on en a besoin je regarde le taux
d'abstention ça c'est pas un hasard les
gens se dénoue tomana indique simplement
parce qu'ils croient que les promesses
soient tenues
il se détourne de l'hermétique aussi
parce qu'ils ne se sentent pas
représentés
pour conclure vous
être consultés par référendum vous
pourrez préférer être consulté sur le
climat ou sur le changement que d'un
parce que je dis ça parce qu'on françois
bayrou a dit bah si le parlement ne
n'examine pas là le le projet peut-être
on peut faire un référendum et ça serait
plus utile que le référendum sur le
climat puisque la clause existe déjà
dans la constitution un référendum sur
le climat je ne sais pas quelles
questions poser c'est notre production
dans le jeu ce que serait sa ronde sur
le climat a pas beaucoup de sens puisque
c'est déjà dans la constitution donc je
vois pas bien l'intérêt de ce référendum
si on doit faire un référendum sans
climat autant faire un vrai référendum
sur et encore je crois que je pense que
c'est le politique qui doit décider et
mener la barque plutôt renault
l'assemblée donc finalement on va
parler un peu des élections régionales
puisque on appris le retrait de jean
michel blanquer qui devait peut-être
mener la liste majoritaire aux élections
régionales en île de france
[Musique]
or nos maux que ministre renonce à se
prononcer à se présenter pendant à une
élection comme celle là après la presse
qui s'était passé pour madame busin vous
pensez que c'est plutôt une bonne chose
ou qui vaut mieux se consacrer à son
rôle de ministre
je pense qu'en ce moment oui il est
quand même beaucoup plus simple le
ministre de l'éducation nationale
s'occupe de ses enseignants et de ses
élèves que ce que tu occupes et d'une
élection ça paraît clair et net il est
en plein dans un dossier quand même très
très difficile avec la crise sanitaire
et ils le gèrent depuis le début puis de
toute façon il voulait pas y aller
s'entraîner dès les quarts faire ou
voulait pas y aller elle fait justement
pour une comédienne vous êtes conseiller
régional seulement mais vous êtes allié
à madame pécresse au conseil général
oui mais on a eu quelques différends de
jus depuis un certain temps
pour une raison simple c'est que moi
j'ai toujours considéré que les
collectivités territoriales ne devait
pas être dirigée de façon clanique
c'est à dire qu'elle devrait diriger le
fasses ton politique sur la base d'un
seul parti majoritaire et ne jamais
laisser la place aux autres
c'est valable pour les municipales c'est
valable pour les intercommunalités
ces voix lapointe département c'est
valable aussi pour la région on n'arrive
pas à se défaire de ça au niveau
national envoyé c'est compliqué au moins
soyons nous bousculer les régiments
énormément de compétences dont la
compétence économique dont on va avoir
vraiment besoin dans les doigts dans les
mois qui viennent il faut être en
capacité de pouvoir travailler avec tout
le monde et de proposer à l'opposition
aux oppositions de travailler où on voit
mais c'est un réflexe quasi humain je
voudrais dire ceci même page et je vais
employer de termes de politique
politicienne et ce clanisme existent ces
espèces de tony régionales existent et
moi j'ai commencé à me détacher
franchement cette majorité régionale dès
l'instant on est rentré dans le
clientélisme sanitaires que ce soit dans
la distribution des masques et bien
orchestrée de manière avec une
communication que j'ai trouvé
outrancière en oubliant précisé van que
c'était l'état qui puise 50% des masques
de la région et puis ça continue avec
les actions et ça je ne supporte pas je
suis désolé je ne le supporte pas donc
oui à une aventure régionales avec nos
amis de la république rend marchés et
d'agir sur des listes majorité
présidentielle mais en amenant aux
citoyens une autre gouvernance est
maintenue jusqu'à demain avec jean-noël
barrot comme tête de liste il a l'air de
vouloir le faire c'est notre collègue à
l'assemblée
et c'est votre règne au diagnostic dieu
je vais vous dire peu importe la tête de
liste enfin on va être être honnête on a
plus de on a plus de deux têtes de liste
de renommée nationale puisque jean
michel blanquer a jeté les looks qu'on
est tous que ce soit laurent saint
martin que ce soit jean noël barrot ou
n'importe qui ça pourrait être moi ça
pourrait que nathalie et limaces on est
tous deux sont députés
on va être honnête
on parle on n'a pas le politique l'aura
mythique hymne valérie pécresse donc
qu'il faut c'est en créer un nouveau
message est une nouvelle fois une
nouvelle gouvernance dans la région de
france qui soit beaucoup plus proche des
citoyens
voilà c'est juste que ça alors après on
déclinera ça évidemment thème par thème
moi je pense que ma vision a - est assez
simple sur tous les problèmes du
quotidien des franciliens
si je n'en gagne si jamais on gagne il
faudrait faire un audit indépendant sur
tous ces points qui gère le quotidien
des franciliens et surtout ses voix et
bien ce qui ne marche pas on doit
s'attaquer d'abord à ça d'abord à sa
main en préservant ce qui marche les
d'abord à ce qui ne marchait pas de
manières et rendre compte
systématiquement de ce qu'on fait
regarder un petit peu ce qui se passe
mais c'est pas que dans la région de
france ne s'est pas tout regardé un
petit haut ce qui se passe entre les
annonces qui sont faites quand vous
faites un budget et la réalité des
réalisations derrière vous avez qu à
prendre lé rapport du ceser
eh ben vous voyez que il ya quand même
une grande différence des cantons
annoncent des choses
le ceser nous met toujours en garde sur
les moyens dont on dispose pour le faire
et en général on annonce des choses
beaucoup plus de choses que ce dont on a
les moyens pour les réaliser et c'est un
peu ça le problème il faut arrêter de
raconter des balivernes aux gens il faut
essayer de les aider est d'être au plus
près des sueurs en toute équité un
citoyen de la seine saint denis
nous on part à moi d'un citoyen des
yvelines en tout cas vous dites vous
détruire à une candidature de la
majorité présidentielle ces élections
régionales on va passer à la loi que
vous discutez actuellement au parlement
la loi qu'on appelait autrefois sur le
séparatisme est ce que cette fois
atteint son but c'est la question va se
poser
[Musique]
alors c'est le projet de loi comportant
les principes de la république puisque
ça s'appelle comme ça maintenant et qui
est sous le feu de deux critiques au
fond il ya il ya ce qu'ils regrettent
que la priorité soit donnée à la
sécurité et à d'identité alors que le
problème du style de celui de réparer le
pays
et puis ça s'est plutôt à gauche est
plus à droite on reproche au projet de
ne pas d'eau mais le vrai sujet c'est à
dire l'islamisme c'est ça mais je dis je
crois que c'est une évidence n est pas
de droite ou de gauche faisait juste
d'être clairvoyant effectivement revenir
après ce ce discours qu'on a attendu
pendant à peu près trois ans du
président macro discours du bureau qui
était plutôt séduisant mais depuis il ne
s'est rien passé
rien est effectivement on a gommé enfin
a été gommé le terme islam mis feu lui
contre les dérives de 2,7
mouvance et comme si tout était passé
alors le pauvre samuel pâtit on l'oubli
on laisse des établissements voté contre
le fait de donner le nom de l'ira pas
son nom il y avait un projet de nommer
des rues salué le pâtis qui sont
également interdits afin qu'ils ne se
font pas parce que les enceintes sont
terrorisés ou se laissent terroriser et
c est là le gouvernement était
totalement absent c'est à dire que on ne
fait plus du tout référence à ça donc
c'est absolument tragique parce que ça
va encore une fois accouché d'une souris
et puis après il faudra pas s'étonner et
peut-être cesser le sujet suivant que
marine le pen arrive à 48% des voix
parce que là dessus je veux dire elle a
même pas besoin de s'exprimer
je veux dire il ya un ras-le-bol s'est
exprimée elle est assez finaude en ce
moment je vous dirais oui on peut
appeler ça comme ça ils peuvent
politiquement elle a même pas le vin
s'exprimer c'est à dire le v10 classe
horizon s'est posé de questions question
inverse stéphane mans sont fines alors
bon il ya la théorie que développe jean
charles lajoie dit est-ce qu'on pourrait
pas développer notre théorie c'est à
dire que au fond une loi c'est pas fait
pour régler le problème du moment c'est
vrai pour fait c'est fait pour durer le
code civil il est encore en activité si
je peux dire la loi de 1905 on applique
toujours est-ce que c'est pas plus
attention au fond de faire une loi qui
n'est pas justement situe juste contre
l'islamisme mais qui englobe beaucoup
beaucoup de problèmes
c'est manifestement enfin en tout cas au
regard de ce que je peux en suivre de
loin le parti qui a été choisie est qui
et qui est parfaitement assumée il était
difficile sur un plan tant politique que
juridique
pardon de parler de droit mais de cibler
exclusivement l'islamisme politique et
je crois que le le le le texte sous
divers aspects le texte qui est en
discussion en préparation englobe cette
question là mais en effet pas seulement
et comme vous le dites il est delà de la
mission d'un législateur ou d'un pouvoir
politique au sens très large du terme
que de que de prévoir on en parlait tout
à l'heure lorsque c'est possible et en
tout cas aussi de prévenir et sur le
plan strictement politique
jean-charles disais à l'instant que
marine le pen engrange sans même
engrange des soutiens sans même avoir à
s'exprimer
je pense qu'elle a fort bien compris que
au fond sur ces questions là à moins
s'exprimer - elle s'exposait parce que
moi je suis assez frappé par la
médiocrité de ses de ses analyses et des
analyses n'ont pas d'elle
personnellement mais de très nombreux
élus ou représentants du rassemblement
national qui manifestement ne travaille
pas correctement leurs dossiers sur ce
point comme sur beaucoup d'autres
d'ailleurs ça c'est quelque chose qui me
qui me qui me frappe de manière assez
assez manifeste donc il ya ici en effet
tout un tout une une difficulté qui est
énorme aussi d'aller se saisir de deux
de ces questions sans stigmatiser je
crois pas que les textes pour l'instant
verse dans la stigmatisation
contrairement à ce que disent certaines
certaines parties de l'opposition
politique
mais en exprimant et en mettant en place
des systèmes des mécanismes efficaces
dire qu'il ne se passe rien c'est pas
vrai le le ministère de l'intérieur le
ministère de la justice ont conduit des
actions alors qu'ils sont des actions
dans les faits qui sont kiki on me
semble-t-il porté leurs fruits je pense
par exemple à des fermetures
administratives de lieux de culte
encore à des dissolutions de
d'associations donc les choses
les choses avancent les choses se
déroulent mais sur un terrain délicat
sur un terrain miné
sur un terrain et faussement laurent
peyrelade et oui je suis parfaitement
d'accord avec stéphane manceau mais je
voulais juste rajouter quelque chose sur
marine le pen
le rassemblement national a préparé un
contre projet de loi sur l aire aussi
d'ailleurs
oui sûr je vais rester juste sur le
rassemblement national puisque on disait
qu'elle était présente
cela étant là le rassemblement national
va pas être thézan dans le cadre de
l'étude de cette fois puisque ils vont
ils ont un projet de loi mais là qui est
ultra populiste et 13 antilles et
ouvertement anti anti islamiste à ces
violences ciblées qui ciblent
complètement et dont j'aurais assez peau
encore ramasser des voix en vue de
l'élection présidentielle le parti
islamiste le terme ne me choque pas
comme il devrait très peu de temps un
hameau de vincent couronne et puis je
voudrais je vais bob rae de bédié
dossier là dessus oui ce projet
oui là dessus effectivement le ratio
national est très véhément dans sa danse
qu'il dit de sa proposition et je suis
d'accord avec florence sur l'analyse en
revanche quand on lit en fait le projet
la proposition faite par la race le
rassemblement national
en réalité il n'ya pas grand chose
dedans il ne propose que des choses qui
existent déjà interdire les
manifestations quito pour l'heure le
public
interdire les prêcheurs de haine etc
je sais déjà des gens des chose qui
existait déjà stéphane mention des états
leur qu'on a fermé des mosquées radical
que on a dissout des associations ac ça
existe déjà
alors en réalité leur à ce moment
nationale je pense que surtout il dit
pas grand-chose publiquement parce qu'il
n'a pas grand chose à dire mais c'est
bien d'avoir lu le projet parce que
voilà on peut être on peut être attiré
par le titre et finalement quand on le
lit il n'y a pas grand chose dedans
bruno myle yens le fait que juste
il ya des critiques des deux côtés à
droite à gauche de cette de ce projet de
loi est ce que ça ne prouve pas que
finalement il est peut-être pas si
mauvais que ça nous sommes tout fait moi
je voudrais faire un tout petit point de
sémantique puisque j'étais au discours
du président quand il a fait son
discours il avait un alien de
séparatisme au pluriel dont séparatisme
islamistes il n'a jamais été question de
gérer noir contre les séparatistes
islamistes islamistes avant c'est le
problème du moment et des séparatismes
d'en avoir d'autres pour cette fois elle
est faite pour englober tout un tas de
possibles séparatisme donc on avait vu
qualifiant il ya des choses qui sont
déclinés dans cette loi il ya des choses
qui sont déjà mises en action notamment
sa tête avait pas un rappelé par
stéphane lançons sur la fermeture de
certains véhicules sur la survie des
solutions certaines associations n'a pas
attendu la loi
puisqu'on peut déjà le faire aujourd'hui
mais en tout cas les choses ont accéléré
et je voudrais vous dire qu'avant que
lavilliers sur discours et avant que
cette loi soit proposée il ya derrière
plus de deux ans de travail dont on a
parlé sur un certain nombre de quartiers
en france où on m'a mis ensemble tous
les services de l'état à savoir
l'éducation nationale la justice la
police les forces de police et
gendarmerie mais aussi la direction
d'anne et les filles la direction des
aides fiscales des finances etc
ils ont tous travaillé ensemble pour
essayer de faire remonter au
gouvernement qu'elles étaient des
conclusions et de voir un petit peu
comment tout se passait dans ces
quartiers-là ou en risque de séparatisme
islamistes ou autres risques de
séparatistes et c'est de cette réflexion
quel est le discours du président de la
république et il a loix cours on va
étudier à partir d'aujourd'hui puisque
yves hier c'était la discussion générale
à l'assemblée nationale mais on rentre
dans le dur à partir d'aujourd'hui un
important que l'ue avait rapidement
parce qu'il faut qu'on se quitte non
c'est la vie mais non il veut attendre
on attend donc un disque de jeu amorcée
voulez mais quel est l'autre séparatisme
ce qui nous inquiète c'est julie il ya
pas que les religions mais bon c'est
vrai il n'ya pas que le séparatisme
islamistes quelle est l'autre je
n'imagine la journée de cellectis ne
pourrait y en avoir
je dis simplement que si on regarde en
terme de religion
moi je ne trouve pas dommage que ses
joueurs mais sur qui d'égalité toutes
les religions voilà je vous le dis
franchement y'a pas faire les
différences entre chacune des religions
ça remet effectivement l'islam sous
contrôle de la république alors qu'il
n'y était plus et ça remet les autres
peut être un type de petit show sous
contrôle même si elle n'en avait pas
besoin
mais au moins tout le monde tout le
monde est mis à la tâche et d'égalité
devant soi et ne les oublient que des
services ils risquent de jeter les
musulmans beaucoup de musulmans dans les
bras de l'islamisme c'était un risque si
oui vous disiez l'origine de
l'observatoire de laïcité pointe depuis
quelques années la montée du problème
des mouvements évangéliques que l'on
voit c'est peu mais qui pourrait
potentiellement constituer dans les
prochaines années un vrai problème
vis-à-vis des dollars mik
mais l'observatoire de la laïcité est
assez contesté et faut le dire aussi
merci merci en tout cas merci en tout
cas à tous d'avoir participé à cette
émission merci bruno milliers de roms
merci florence mercadé choqué et merci
jean charles lajoie dis à très vite à
bientôt un nouveau du bureau de baffes
[Musique]